ladies and gentlemen it is Andrew Ray
[Applause]
of what you've done
feel impressive which is rare thank you
so much wow you deserve nothing left but
today we're going to make something
special tell us what it is so you guys
were cool enough to get me into a
screening for Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania which I'm so excited about
and I was I was I'm on the lookout for
food that's my job uh to see if there's
gonna be any food in it and I was
thrilled to see some pizza and uh so it
had Peppers it had zucchini on it and
because they're in San Francisco I think
it was a sourdough pizza so that's what
we're gonna make today I love sourdough
it's my favorite of the bread yeah
[Applause]
yeah
uh let's start uh good
you take over
um a little pizza oh um we can start
with the little pizza okay all right so
they brought out this little tiny pizza
and they put some some Ant-Man stuff on
it and blew up so I like using for white
pizza because it looked like there
wasn't any red tomato sauce a Bianco yes
Pizza Bianca yes I I don't get that
right either the uh I like using
Bechamel now we have to sort of cheat
today okay sourdough if you're on
Instagram you know everything about
sourdough and uh it it takes a solid
week to cultivate because you're using
wild yeast you know we need to let them
grow and eats and all this stuff so
we're making a cheaters sourdough
starter uh this is
right here this is the starter you can
see it's alive and well so this is just
uh equal parts flour white flour Rye
flour and water and a big heaping
teaspoon of yeast let that sit overnight
now uh my next shortcut hack cheat is to
make this dough in the food processor so
we're adding that to the food processor
along with I think it's 350 grams of
bread flour okay and we've got a lot of
sugar yeast love sugar so that's two
tablespoons of sugar and then it's a
little bit more yeast just to make sure
that you know just in case these guys
didn't make it through the night we got
some extra okay and then we're going to
cover this up and then we've got a 180
mil I think of ice cold water you want
it nice and cold ice cold
there it goes you can see it turned into
a ball of dough as it goes around
let's pretend that was 45 seconds
perfect fully needed pizza dough and
then
you would top the rounds with the
Bechamel yes so we can do that if you
want perfect I feel like I'm doing
everything here do you want to do this
oh I know I'm I'm like just sitting here
chatting why do you do the cheese the
cheese is the funnest all right so let's
try sprinkle stuff on here yeah just
sprinkle it right on top okay perfect
awesome and then this pizza had zucchini
and little uh sliced bell peppers on it
look at them yeah they're tiny little
guys oh you know what I forgot what
oh yeah I forgot about our little guy no
do we have many here he gets one
zucchini
okay so should I can I yeah go for it
cover it okay we've dressed our pizza
yeah
time and temp in the oven while your
oven as hot as it will possibly go you
want to preheat it for an hour before
with a pizza stone in it because you
want it to really blast it out in you
know in life we would take both of these
and they would go over here we're just
they're gonna oh all right oh there's
the oven um there's the oven and then
we're gonna bring over this guy because
all I want to do is get it into my mouth
and it's so hot by the way I don't know
should we just eat it yeah let's dig in
exactly
oh my God
I love it well Andrew we heard that you
were celebrating something very special
and I was wondering if you would stick
around
um to close out the show with us 100
okay
when we come back I'm gonna sit down
with one of the stars of Ant-Man and the
boss quantumania William Jackson Harper
I can't stop something my face we'll be
right back
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]